Hey man. Ah, yeah I've been
thinking about it.
It's too soon.
I can't do this.
Aww, come on mate,
it's been three months.
Alright, it's time
to get back out there.
It's just a date, it's not like
you're going into
the Hunger Games.
Alright, I'm just
going to say it.
It's weird that you're always
referencing your own movies.
Oh, sassy Josh, you are
catching fire, buddy.
Yeah, see like that
doesn't make any sense.
Just remember two things:
be yourself
and always compliment her nose.
It's a classic Hemsworth
one-two-punch.
That worked with Miley?
Listen, I'll be right there
with you. Fly, Mockingjay!
Wait, I have one other-
Hey. Sara?
That's me.
I'm Josh.
I like your sweater.
Thank you. I love your nose.
Did you just say you
like my nose?
No. Excuse me, though. Sorry.
Hey.
How's it going?
Did you do the nose thing yet?
She loved it, didn't she?
What are you talking about?
We just talked five seconds ago.
Yeah, I know,
I'm just so excited.
Hey, tell her
you love her scarf.
Okay, I'm going to go now.
Wait a second, how did you-
Ah!
It's me. Get back to her,
you're doing good.
I'm sorry. I think we got off
on the wrong foot.
What I meant to say of course
is I love your scarf.
Thank you. I like your taste.
This is good, okay.
Good.
Josh. Josh. Josh.
What the fuck are you
doing down there?
Did you mention the scarf yet?
Ask her if she seen
Love Song.
Please stay out of this.
Girls love the Love
Song, I was in it.
I know. I know you were in that.
You're ruining this for me.
Stay down, stay down.
He's talking to his penis.
Why do I always get
the psychopaths?
I need you to stay down there.
If I need you later
I will call you, okay?
Let's order, we should order.
Waiter.
Ah, I see you're ready
to order Josh.
I mean, complete stranger.
Ah, isn't it romantic.
You two must be on a date.
Isn't it Romantic is actually
a new film, by the way.
Yeah, we know that.
I didn't know that and I
don't care.
Bullshit. How's Josh doing,
he's such a good guy isn't he?
Josh, wait wait wait.
My friend, Liam.
This is just a costume,
I'm not really a waiter.
Just like in the movies.
Just giving my friend
Josh a little dating help here.
You were Cyrano de
Bergerac-ing me?
Oh Latin! She's a smart one.
Hey, did Josh compliment
your nose yet?
Excuse me, Liam. I'm just going
to go to the restroom.
She's going the wrong way.
She's actually using the exit.
Yep, there she goes.
Or she's going to pee
in the street.
That's a bit weird,
isn't it?
You don't need
something like anyway.
Come on, let's get
some beers on you, eh?
Waiter? Real waiter?
Hey, who's your favorite
Hemsworth?
You're in the top three.
That's good.